consider the following
imagine two rooms
inside each room is a switch
in one room there is a man who flips his
switch according to a coin flip if he
lands heads the switch is on if he lands
tails the switch is off
in the other room a woman switches her
light based on a blind guess she tries
to simulate randomness without a coin
then we start a clock and they make
their switches in unison
can you determine which light bulb is
being switched by a coin flip
the answer is yes but how
and the trick is to think about
properties of each sequence rather than
looking for any specific patterns
for example first we may try to count
the number of ones and zeros which occur
in each sequence this is close but not
enough since they will both seem fairly
even
the answer is to count sequences of
numbers such as runs of three
consecutive switches
a true random sequence will be equally
likely to contain every sequence of any
length
this is called the frequency stability
property and is demonstrated by this
uniform graph the forgery is now obvious
humans favor certain sequences when they
make guesses resulting in uneven
patterns such as we see here
one reason this happens is because we
make the mistake of thinking certain
outcomes are less random than others but
realize there is no such thing as a
lucky number
there is no such thing as a lucky
sequence
if we flip a coin ten times it is
equally likely to come up all heads all
tails or any other sequence you can
think of